you come down that red carpet with all
the flashbulbs and the shouting and the
questions about the dress and you forget
that the only wardrobe choices that
really matter are the five that we're
about to see they are the best costumes
of the year drawn from several decades
by five brilliant designers almost
culinary confections themselves the
delectable designs of nominee Gabriella
Pascucci were a visual feast for
moviegoers in Charlie and the Chocolate
Factory the colorful kimonos and customs
of an era long gone were the inspiration
for the costumes created by nominee
Colleen Atwood and Memoirs of a Geisha
some of the actresses wore nothing at
all but nominee Sandy Powell kept the
rest of the cast well covered in 40s era
costumes for mrs. Henderson presents
novelist Jane Austen herself would
surely nod with approval at the 18th
century British apparel created by
nominee Jacqueline Duran for Pride and
Prejudice
just like his music the life and loves
of Johnny Cash were full of fireworks
and so were the costumes created by
nominee Ariane Phillips or walk the line
and the Oscar goes to Colleen Atwood
Memoirs of a Geisha
this is the second Academy Award and
sixth nomination for Colleen f-word she
took home her first Oscar for Chicago
thank you all very much so many people
to to thank for making this film it was
an effort that circled the globe and
came together here in Los Angeles thanks
to Sony Pictures who were brave enough
to make a movie about a woman fantastic
thank you very much - Rob Marshall my
fantastic director whose vision I only
share to my amazing daughters who are
with me here tonight to my team of
people who really kept it together for
me Sheryl Christine and Colleen and to
the most beautiful cast anybody could
ever dream of dressing and most of all
to the people of Japan who gave me so
much knowledge and grace thank you